les choses sont claires les choses sont
très très clair du côté de chez huawei
huawei a fait les choix quelles que
soient les choses qui peuvent se passer
du côté des états unis et de l'embargo
américain d'utiliser exclusivement son
propre état ou d'applications et de ne
prendre aucun autre il ne ferons pas
machine arrière et j'utilise donc la
galerie la galerie qui se déploie la
galerie qui devient de plus en plus
importante avec pleins d'applications
donc aujourd'hui ce que je vais faire je
vais vous parler de la galerie je vais
vous montrer ce qu'est la galerie
comment elle fonctionne je vais vous
expliquer comment télécharger vos
différentes applications qu'elles soient
présentes ou pas sur la galerie et je
vais aussi vous expliquer comment
transférer les données de votre
smartphone qui lui par contre utiliser
service google pour aller sur un
smartphone de huawei qui lui par contre
utiliser les services de voirie on va
commencer par le commencement vous venez
d'acheter des derniers smartphones de
huawei est ici notamment le paie 40 pro
sauf que ce p 40 pro tout de suite il
est vide
vous n'avez absolument rien dessus et
vous voulez apporter les données de
votre ancien téléphone sans votre
nouveau téléphone pour ça c'est simple
une application intérieur et elle
s'appelle faune clown femme clown c'est
cette application vous allez voir c'est
extrêmement simple vous téléchargez
faune clown sur votre ancien téléphone
et vous l'avez bien évidemment sur notre
nouveau smartphone de warwick pour vous
le dis installé phone clown sur le
téléphone d'origine donc sur votre
ancien téléphone vous choisissez sur
votre smartphone ce que vous voulez
partager et le transfère vestiaire très
facilement d'un téléphone à l'autre
j'ai donc récupéré toutes mes
applications ou presque toutes mes
photos mes contacts et mon agenda
et ça ça marche aussi bien avec un
smartphone android que ayo ce donc là
vous avez récupéré quasiment toutes les
applications de votre ancien smartphone
votre nouveau smartphone mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là parce que maintenant
vous allez télécharger vos applications
directement dans la galerie pour bien
télécharger de nouvelles applications
vous allez dans la galerie est située
juste ici vous avez donc un catalogue
d'applications avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'applications ici toutes les
nouveautés vous allez trouver sur
l'accueil
elles sont également classés par
catégorie g automobile boissons business
company vous avez également le
classement des meilleures applications
vous pouvez gérer toutes vos
applications avec notamment les mises à
jour vous avez beaucoup d'applications
qu'on utilise au quotidien notamment des
applications d'un fond quelques réseaux
sociaux pour voyager pour s'amuser et
vous avez beaucoup d'applications
classés par thème dans le nombre ne
cesse d'augmenter
une fois que vous avez trouvé
l'application qui vous intéressent vous
cliquiez sur vous arrivez sur la fiche
détaillée de l'application avec le nom
le nombre de téléchargements la note
vous avez tout une présentation avec
différentes
de l'application tout un descriptif 1 à
propos qui vous dit le tarif de
l'application la taille la version la
date de sortie l'éditeur la limitation
de la chine y en a eu d'autres
applications populaires et vous avez des
informations son éditeur qui sont situés
juste en dessous mais vous avez
également des commentaires vous voyez la
note globale tous les commentaires sur
l'application seo permet donc d'avoir un
vrai feedback vous pouvez venir partager
ici l'application avec huawei cher et
sur les différents réseaux sociaux et
lorsque vous êtes conquis vous avez plus
qu à cliquer sur installer une fois
qu'elles installent et vous n'avez plus
qu'à cliquer sur ouvrir que vous arrivez
directement dans votre application
bon ça c'est bien mais je n'ai pas
toutes les applications je voudrais
puisque facebook
bref ça paie notamment instagram ne sont
pas disponibles rassurez vous il existe
une technique très simple pour venir et
télécharger il ya deux moyens le premier
vous allez sur le site du développeur
sur le site de l'application par exemple
whatsapp qui met à disposition son à
pékin le rapper cas ça vous parle pas
forcément une app et casque un programme
d'installation de l'application dans
votre smartphone ça c'est un peu
complexe par faciles à trouver et on
semblait alors rassurez-vous vous ai
trouvé la bonne solution est la bonne
solution si cette application qui
s'appelle trumap par se trouve à vous
permet de trouver toutes vos
applications et les installer très
facilement même si elles sont pas
disponibles sur l'app galerie ça va vous
donner tous les moyens pour télécharger
instagram watts à wez et bien d'autres
encore par exemple moi je veux
télécharger ou whatsapp je vois que
l'application est disponible sur le site
officiel j'ouvre avec mon navigateur et
je te vient la télécharger directement
ici je clique en bas téléchargez et
ensuite je vais dans les téléchargements
je vois donc que j'ai un fichier qui
s'appelle whatsapp points à pk qui est
en train de se télécharger c'est le
fichier qui me permettra d'installer et
ça permettra donc d'utiliser whatsapp
directement dans mon smartphone j'arrive
donc sur cette page tu peux venir
installer mon appli whatsapp
installation réussie
est ce que vient ouvrir mon application
très facilement bon faut faire la même
chose avec beaucoup d'application
je vous laisserai essayer maintenant on
a récupéré quasiment toutes nos
applications il se peut qu'il y ait
encore quelques unes qui sont
réfractaires notamment youtube et hubert
alors rassurez-vous vous pouvez quand
même les utiliser
grâce à la version web rien ne vous
empêche collector youtube.com pour me
regarder toutes les vidéos de monsieur
grrrr vous mettez en plein écran et ça
marche parfaitement bien vous vous
connectez sur ribéry de fournir
commander tous les petits plats qui vous
feront plaisir donc là vous avez une
solution complète mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là parce que si vous aviez un
smartphone sur android et toutes vos
données sont chez google
vous pouvez les récupérer grâce à google
takeout vous la chasse à votre moteur de
recherche google takeout une fois que
vous êtes identifié sur google vous
allez pouvoir sélectionner tout ce que
vous voulez télécharger en termes de
données que ce soit des achats
réservation l'actualité l'agenda toutes
vos données
google quelle que soit la catégorie vous
pouvez venir les récupérer les
télécharger et croyez moi là il y en a
un paquet bon après vous le faites très
rapidement vous avez un service de
musique un service de vidéos dans le
syndic de musique vous allez pouvoir
trouver plein de morceaux à venir
écouter tel que dans les vidéos vous
avez tout un service de vod avec plein
plein plein plein de films vous avez des
tendances avec pas mal de petites vidéos
différentes du sport du divertissement
du lifestyle plein chaîne différente
un autre point intéressant dans la
galerie vous allez dans le gestionnaire
en bas vous cliquez sur paquet
d'installation et vous allez voir toutes
les applications que vous avez installé
directement via une api cas et vous
pouvez venir les supprimer très
facilement ici si vous le souhaitez
tandis que son gestionnaire
d'installation vous avez accès à toutes
les applications qui sont installés sur
votre smartphone foyer c'est intéressant
le boulot café huawei pour que vous
puissiez récupérer toutes vos données
vos applications très facilement de
différentes manières s'est pas
complètement par faye et les
applications que vous n'avez pas
néanmoins le nombre d'applications
disponibles sur la guérite ont vraiment
à se développer
ce qu'on voit et ce qui est clair c'est
owen on est qu'à ses débuts sur cette
nouvelle histoire sur la nouvelle
histoire de la galerie si on revient un
petit peu quelques mois en arrière
lorsque je vous parlais du may 30 pro
qui était un très bon smartphone mais
qui malheureusement n'était pas
utilisable en l'état
aujourd'hui se mettre en pro devient
utilisable grâce à la galerie avec
pleins d'applications qu'on utilise ici
en france et en europe
au quotidien les choses ont continué à
se développer en tout cas la contre
attaque de wyatt suez est très puissante
très forte comment en quelques mois ils
ont réussi à développer cette galerie
qui marchait et qui était connu en asie
mais qui en europe n'était pas
particulièrement utilisé parce que pas
d'application aujourd'hui ça devient une
solution intéressante cette donne une
alternative vraiment viable et quand je
vois le bloc était réalisée on appelle
quelques mois j'imagine même pas ce qui
va arriver dans les mois à venir sur feu
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que maintenant vous voyez comment
ça marche vous pourriez vous laisser
séduire qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette galerie qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ces différentes solutions et
différentes manières de venir récupérer
tout votre contenu pour l'importer dans
votre nouveau smartphone de huawei sais
pas ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire mais bon ça plutôt
intéressant c'est pas encore parfait
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
vous pouvez récupérer quasiment tout
votre contenu extrêmement facilement et
ça c'est vachement bien à vous me dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain pour utilisé par les textes
des bisous à demain ciao
[Musique]
ah lalala lalala